so
when you first created this reddit
thread what year was it
2012 2012 and what were you doing then
like what sparked you
to want to create a subreddit and did
you have any idea that it would become
as popular as it did
no i don't think anyone can imagine that
it would have grown the way that it did
but look i meant
my early 30s at the time i was single no
kids no dependents
uh i was working at a at a bank uh
making
very good money and so i had my typical
retirement fund or whatever but i had
uh extra money late you know left over
in which i wasn't afraid to lose
and uh so i decided to start throwing it
into the stock market started learning
some more about it
decided to get more aggressive there's
ways to get really really aggressive
with the stocks and i said you know
this is worth uh this is worth a shot if
i can take these couple thousand dollars
a month that i can throw at this thing
and
lose it that's fine and if i make a ton
of money and i become a gazillionaire
then that's even better so let's give it
a shot
and i couldn't find any place that
online where people were willing to do
that
there's because there's conservative uh
forums where they're like you have to
diversify and you have to put your
portfolio into a thing with low
commissions
uh and then you have some real
professional day traders that are really
technical and it's
it's a profession and they're really
good at it and that's the ones that are
looking at like the chart patterns and
whatnot
but they wake up in the morning they
have this routine they study the stocks
they read the news i don't know what
they do but
that's their nine to five or whatever
but i was looking for just having fun
like i think netflix is gonna go up or i
think
facebook's gonna beat expectations with
the quarterly and
and not finding a place like that i just
created it and obviously it was a huge
demand because it just grew by itself it
doubled every year in size
yeah now like so you were just like
getting into
actively trading stocks so you were like
putting your money in there and you were
trying to were you like
what you call day trading where you like
buy you're buying and selling
[ __ ] every single day like i don't know
[ __ ] [ __ ] about stocks like i'm like
yeah talk to me like i'm a fifth grader
yeah so i think you know it start it
starts it starts off slow right it
starts life all right
you see the news and you see oh google's
going up a lot because they're going to
start
creating an android telephone it's going
to compete with the iphone and blah blah
blah and you're like all right cool i
think that's going to make some money
and so you go ahead and you put that
money uh into google and then you just
kind of watch it and it doesn't go up as
far and you kind of get a little
desperate you're like come on this
supposed to be the android phone it's
supposed to take over the world why is
the stock not going up like crazy
so then i take the money out after a
couple days and then i'd see the stock
just shoot up after i
got out of that trade i'm like all right
all right let's take a different look
had i
bet had i about to stock at the right
moment that would have done better there
has to be a better technique
and so it starts by i have a good idea
because i like the company
and then realizing well [ __ ] like they
they've google has been announcing this
android phone for years
uh why would it just go up on a random
tuesday when i decided to invest in it
all right
i guess that makes sense just because i
found out about it doesn't mean that the
stock's going to go up on that
particular day
and so that kind of leads me to doing
shorter and shorter trades and so they
have something called swing trading and
that's usually something where you buy
the stock and you hold it for a couple
days
and then you have day trading which is
you buy the stock and you sell it that
same day
and then i discovered stock options
right so stocks go up and down and you
can pretty much
bet if you think they're going to go up
you buy the stock and if you think it's
going to go down you do something called
short sell
but you get a one to one if you have a
hundred bucks and the stock goes up five
percent
you make five bucks uh stock options all
of a sudden
cross my table and i'm like oh wait a
second these things are leveraged
meaning
with that same hundred bucks uh if the
stock goes up five percent i can make
500 percent you know i could make 500
bucks
that sounds pretty attractive uh and
and because they swing so violently you
definitely just want to be in there and
out really quickly so i
i made this little journey which i'm
guessing a lot of people do
buying stock options buying like put
like like betting on whether it's going
to go up or down right
yep now can you explain that a little
bit
dumber for me i i still don't quite i
mean i've had a million people try to un
explain these stock options i've watched
all the infographic videos on youtube
all the crash course videos and it still
seems very [ __ ] confusing
here's the deal i learned something from
robin hood uh
in their ability to simplify really
complicated things
stock options can be very complicated
there's people that have written their
phds on how those things
work there's some mathematical equations
that are you know from
difficulty differential equations with
with very very sophisticated
uh and difficult to understand concepts
and i'm guessing that the stuff that you
saw
were trying to dumb those concepts down
robin hood does something magical which
is like well you think the stock's going
to go up you buy calls
and then robin's cool because you can
answer with like an arrow that points up
and it's colored green right or
you think the stock's going to go down
you buy the put calls and
then you answer with the red arrow uh
that's
that's pretty much it at the essence
what the stock
options are if you decide to buy a stock
option you're essentially buying
a hundred shares of that stock right
i'm simplifying this grotesquely but for
all intents and purposes that's all you
really need to know
if you think facebook's gonna go up you
go out there and you buy a call option
and under various scenarios if facebook
goes up by one dollar
because you own 100 shares of it or
control 100 shares
it can go up by a hundred dollars and
this call option
instead of costing the full price of of
the 100 shares it costs
significantly less so
if i were to guess right now as a call
option for facebook is probably
300 bucks right so you buy one call you
put 300
in there and that thing's gonna control
about a hundred shares
and the price of facebook is also about
300 so so you can either buy one share
or buy
100 shares for that same 300 bucks
that's all that really people need to
know and that's a lot of how people
really use them
they can be so much cooler than that and
they are much more complicated but
that's all the
the the people that you see making
millions of dollars that's all they're
really doing right
do you think the purpose of making all
this [ __ ] so confusing
is just so they could manipulate it
however they [ __ ] want and make all
the money they want without getting in
trouble
it is but you know that's the beauty of
it i think that's the reason why this
thing made so much
news is because retail traders from
their cell phones were able to pull the
pants down on the complexity it can be
complicated if you want me to really
explain the nitty gritties of it like
i'll put you to sleep
but but it's as easy as answering with
that red arrow or that green arrow from
your robin hood account like that's all
that they needed to do to realize oh
okay
all you need to do is take the opposite
side of the trade you think it's going
to suck you think gamestop is going to
go out of business because of
coronavirus or whatever because they're
outdated
that's fine i believe that you're wrong
and i'm just going to take the other
side of the trade and behind the scenes
there's all this
complex [ __ ] that nobody understands but
they don't really need to understand
and that's that's the beauty of this
they proved the fact that you don't need
to have
your certificate your cfa sort of
certification or your master's in
finance or whatever
you could just have to answer with the
button with the green one or
the red one um so
my basic understanding and maybe you can
kind of like
uh educate me a little bit better on on
the stock part of this but my unders my
only understanding of the stock market
is i read a book by i read a tony
robbins book a couple years ago
and basically said if you don't want to
understand if you don't have the time or
patience to understand everything about
stocks
just buy the s p 500 and invest x amount
of dollars in it every single month the
rest of your life and you'll be a
millionaire by the time you're 50 or 60
or 70 or whatever it may be
so that's all i do when it comes to the
stock market i just buy what one share a
month
on the s p 500 am i
am i an idiot or am i no i'm doing
something no not at all you're doing it
perfect and that's exactly what i was
saying earlier like if you don't
have the time or interest or whatever
then that's that's the exact example
that i use because it's such a good
example and it's and it's a very
good approach with the stock market you
can do
there's a spectrum you can do crazy yolo
gambling where you do all or nothing
bets and you can quite literally take a
thousand dollars and turn it into a
hundred thousand dollars in one day
or in two days and it happens more
frequently than than
you'd imagine and then on the other side
of the spectrum
you have this diversified slow
dividend uh collecting
uh low fee etf or
or investment that pretty much just
keeps up with inflation right like
because inflation's not a thing that
we're gonna get rid of either
and so if you put your money in stocks
and the dollar you know
the the value of the dollar goes down
then then you don't lose
your whatever savings you have because
your dollar amount goes up on par
those are the two extremes those those
two exist and the idea is where do you
want to be
on the spectrum i personally also do
that i have my that's where my
retirement is and i throw my money into
the stocks
on a very regular basis and the stocks
go down and i keep buying it the stocks
go back up and i keep buying it and
that's it you know that's that's how i'm
going to retire
but i also like 500 i i like to do both
i do the s p 500 and i throw a little
bit in there in tech because if you see
uh if you see what it like i saw a great
tweet by someone that said
what was it 20 years ago the top
companies in the s
p 500s sorry the the oh this was by
berkshire hathaway
in fact this was from warren buffett's
company it wasn't in the s p 500 at
least i don't think anymore it was just
like
the biggest companies in the world and
there's a list of 20 and you can see
like the bank of japan the bank of this
the bank of that this bank the
sucky moral whatever and the top 20
companies were almost all banks and now
the biggest companies in the world is
facebook
apple google tesla you know it's all
tech companies and so there is a kind of
a shift
that's going towards tech and those and
and the fact that you had banks
previously take that top spot is mainly
because they control a lot of money
money makes a lot of money so it makes
sense that money the ones that with a
lot of money are at the top but now
tech is getting into into the banking
industry you can
you know they have this whole fintech
industry where you can now
get credit cards to pretty much all
these tech companies and they're
starting to do crypto stuff and so
i lean a little heavier towards the tech
so i so i i have both the nasdaq and the
smp
i